una de las zonas más remotas de la
amazonía brasileña fue la última
localización de don phillips periodista
británico y de un experto en asuntos
indígenas brasileño bruno araujo pereira
que estaban en medio de una
investigación sobre medio ambiente en la
región
un tío
[Música]
exigimos a los organismos competentes
que intensifiquen la búsqueda porque
todavía tenemos una pequeña esperanza de
encontrarlos aunque no encuentre con
vida el amor de mi vida hay que
encontrarlos
encuentro de mil diez mil
no esté en contra
ambos fueron vistos por última vez en el
valle de javarí región fronteriza con
perú que alberga el mayor número de
tribus indígenas no contactadas del
mundo y fuertemente asediada por la
minería ilegal y el tráfico de drogas
durante su viaje phillips y araujo
recibieron amenazas por parte de grupos
mineros ilegales de la zona y según the
gardian periódico con el que phillips
colabora presenciaron un enfrentamiento
entre indígenas y hombres armados por lo
que se teme por su seguridad escolar
chávez está lleno de vitalidad es mi
hermano mayor lo admiro lo quiero a lo
que
apenas nos preocupa que hayan sido
secuestrados por alguien que quería
silenciar la luz que estaban arrojando
sobre las actividades ilegales en la
zona
philip se está sentado en salvador de
bahía desde donde ha colaborado con
diferentes periódicos entre ellos the
washington post the new york times' y
araujo es un antiguo funcionario del
gobierno encargado de proteger a tribus
no contactadas en brásil
el gobierno desplegado un operativo en
la zona para dar con su paradero pero no
descarta que ya hayan sido ejecutados